up until now there was never a nexus
tablet there were nexus phones but no
tablet the motorola zoom for example was
a 10-inch tablet running stock android
but it's not a nexus and the asus
transformers run a very close version of
stock android but not exactly and
they're not nexuses so when google
announced a tablet they made a few very
curious decisions behind the scenes and
came up with this
the nexus 7. the 8 gigabyte nexus 7
costs 200. you know what else cost two
hundred dollars the eight gigabyte ipod
touch okay so that gives you a good idea
of the bang for buck that you get out of
this guy and that bang comes from a 1.3
gigahertz quad core tegra 3 chip and 1
gigabyte of ram all behind the scenes
powering android 4.1 jelly bean now i'm
not going to restate all of the reasons
why android 4.1 is so awesome but
there's an annotation and a link below
to my video covering all of the best new
features of the operating system but
most notably during my time with the
device project butter as i spend more
time with it i've actually noticed it's
more universal around the entire
operating system than i first thought it
was people always demonstrate it just by
swiping around the launcher you know
between home screens and through the app
tray but it's even inside of apps too so
scrolling through websites in chrome
turning pages and books and navigating
through apps the overall touch response
everywhere just makes it seem super fast
and that's going to keep the tablet
feeling newer longer and i'm not even
much of a gamer but even the games i
played seem to perform better and at
higher frame rates thanks to butter now
the apps the apps are very important
when talking about the nexus 7. a lot of
people will criticize it saying android
still lacks tablet apps which can be
true but thanks to the smaller 7-inch
display and the resolution it handles
phone optimized apps just as well as it
handles tablet optimized apps so it's
kind of like a hybrid between the two
and let's get a peek into the best of
both worlds now not all apps are
compatible with android 4.1 yet so if
your favorite third-party app isn't
compatible send an email to that
developer and there are some pretty
sweet new apps being updated to take
advantage of the 7-inch screen so that's
pretty cool one thing that's also
different with the larger display since
it's a seven inch tablet is
notifications and google's created an
interesting spin-off of the regular
android phone's pull-down notifications
the pull-down tray here doesn't take up
the whole screen it's just in the center
when you're in portrait mode and you get
all that neat new stuff with expandable
notifications that google has baked into
android 4.1 some very useful stuff in
here neat features and third-party apps
can also take advantage of these
expandable notifications but the neat
thing is once you go into landscape it
shifts over to the left hand side so you
can actually still kind of see what's
going on in the background which is nice
and you'll notice though that the nexus
7 does go back to feeling like a large
phone when it doesn't let you rotate the
home screen into landscape so like some
of the bigger tablets out there they go
straight to landscape but the nexus 7
doesn't let you rotate the home to
landscape mode just yet overall though
if you're concerned about the seven inch
form factor not feeling large enough to
be different from your phone
trust me it is for example after using
the galaxy s3 for about a month the
current iphone seemed like this i'm
going from a 7 inch tablet back down to
a 4.8 inch phone it has a similar effect
i still use the nexus 7 as a one-handed
device though but that may just because
i have huge hands not really sure either
way i mentioned at the beginning of the
video that it's a 200 tablet and we've
seen some pretty crappy 200 tablets in
terms of build quality but this one's
fine trust me to keep it thin like this
it's sealed into one rigid design so you
have to twist it really hard to get it
to flex and this also means no
expandable storage or replaceable
battery but no worries about the battery
the 4325 milliamp hour battery lasts
plenty long easily a full two days of
regular use there's no camera on the
back of the nexus 7 but let's face it
it's a tablet you don't really need it
but there is a front-facing camera and
plenty of apps in the play store that
can take advantage of it the only gripe
i have about the exterior was the
placement of these buttons yes it's a
one-handed device but that doesn't mean
you have to put all the buttons on one
side i found myself blindly reaching to
turn the volume up on a youtube video
and i press the power button right next
to it instead which turned the screen
off so that's a little bit annoying but
i would have liked to see the power and
volume buttons a little bit further
apart oh and that plastic back does help
wifi reception it's almost always full
strength like a baus and a small touch
is the elongated speaker on the back
which makes it really difficult to block
the whole thing accidentally and the
display on the front while it isn't a
retina display or anything crazy like
that is 200 bucks it's more than 200
pixels per inch at 1280 by 720 and it
looks damn impressive anyway now it's
wi-fi only and this one happens to be
eight gigabytes and that's a bad combo
if you're one of those people who's away
from wi-fi all the time and wants to
save stuff for offline use which is why
i'm thinking go with the 16 gigabyte or
there may be something along the lines
of a nexus 10 perhaps with a cellular
radio somewhere in the near future
so in the end is the nexus 7 a good
product is it worth the 200
for this eight gig version here google
spends about 200 to make it and then
sells it for about 200
but they're trusting that you will spend
enough time in the google play store on
this device to start giving google more
money and make it worth itself they even
give you a 25 credit to the google play
store so once you go through that google
play credit you run out of 25 bucks
maybe a couple hours after you get it or
a couple of days or a couple of months
but once you finally run out of that
free credit you're going to start
spending money on apps books movies
games tv shows and all kinds of things
like that and that'll hopefully be
giving google a lot more money than when
you originally purchased this tablet
that's what they're banking on and
that's why they made a nexus tablet for
the google play store all the ads you
see for the nexus are talking about the
fact that this is built for the google
play store and that's exactly why they
even give you a free copy of like i
showed you the transformers dark of the
moon movie hoping that you'll enjoy the
experience so much that you'll want to
buy more movies in the google play store
and give google more money overall
though i was interested in what they
were going to come up with for the first
nexus tablet because there was no nexus
tablet before this there was a motorola
zoom which also happens to be stock but
this is the first nexus tablet and they
decided to go with a seven inch form
factor and that sort of intrigued me but
i turned out to like it a lot so what do
you guys think if you enjoyed this video
review feel free to give it a thumbs up
and leave your thoughts in the comment
section below and you can see i'm
probably already answering the comments
down there so open conversation to talk
about the nexus 7. either way thanks for
watching this video hope you enjoyed it
and looking forward to the next one
thank you for watching
talk to you later
peace
you